[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings we have a
big update today in the case of a man
who has spent decades arguing he's been
wrongly imprisoned after more than 44
years vincent simmons is now a free man
yesterday a judge ruled he had not
received a fair trial back in 1977 when
he was convicted of attempted aggravated
rape the decision is partly based on
evidence that's been available for years
our lead national correspondent david
begneau recently sat down with simmons
accusers twins who were 14 years old
back in 1977
now he has spoken to simmons and david
joins us from angola louisiana david
good morning what incredible reporting
vlad good morning to you hello everyone
listen vincent served 44 years here at
louisiana state penitentiary but he was
supposed to serve a hundred that was the
sentence
for the last 30 or so years he kept
trying to tell judges i didn't get a
fair trial and here's the information
and they just dismissed him left and
right get out of here get out of here
but yesterday there was a judge who said
to him
i believe that you did not get a fair
trial in fact that judge's daddy nearly
30 years ago dismissed vincent's attempt
but this judge said your rights were
denied they were violated
and you get a fair trial and we were
there for all of it
[Music]
when the shackled vincent simmons
arrived at the of oils parish courthouse
in a prison baby
he was carrying a bible when his
accusers karen and sharon sanders the
twins that he was convicted of sexually
assaulting when they were 14 years old
walked to the courthouse
they paused to pray simmons had been in
prison for 44 years and tried for most
of that time to get his conviction
overturned you've done this 16 times at
least yes so this would be 17
you think this will be the time yes sir
we walked alongside simmons as he was
about to face a judge
who had recently examined information
that was available in 1977 but it was
not presented at his trial
that was information that he and his
attorneys believed may have changed his
conviction
for attempted aggravated rape
it took less than an hour for judge
billy bennett to say that there had been
a lapse in louisiana justice in 1977.
you free brother you were free
and that vincent simmons deserves a new
trial
and that is when the shackles came off
of his feet the district attorney said
he will not retry simmons
his accusers sharon and karen sanders
now 59 years old decided to stand down
he went in guilty
he's guilty now
and guess what he will die guilty yes
so i'm
i'm happy i got 44 years all right let's
go
it was that moment like for you when you
realized that what the judge said
meant
you were a free man yeah it dawned on me
this is it
you know
man you've been waiting all these years
for this you'll turn 70 on thursday
did you think you would die in prison
yes
and i had visions
of the prison gates opening
up and i'm walking through them are you
mad at anyone no i'm not mad so you're
not mad at the women no
i'm not mad at them
i mean that when i tell them i forgive
them
that's what i mean
forgiveness
the judge said several times on the
bench
i do not know whether mr simmons is
innocent or guilty
does it bother you that you walk out of
here a free man
but with the suspicion by some people
that you may still be guilty well
i still believe that
even though the amount
just like people
people gonna be people
and some of them gonna say oh he's
guilty
you know despite the fact that
they had no evidence
but before he could be free a remarkable
thing happened
louisiana prison officials required that
the shackles go back on
so he could go back to prison
to be processed i'm just telling you
he's he's a free man and though his
lawyer pushed back you can't be in jail
tonight like that that's not like a good
that would not be a good thing
he would load up again and travel
another two hours back to louisiana
state penitentiary the largest maximum
security prison in the nation where at
sunset vincent simmons walked out oh
yeah
of the place he has been held in since
he was 25 years old hey man
the judge said on the bench yesterday i
want to be clear i'm not telling you
that vincent simmons is guilty or
innocent i'm just telling you he
deserves a new trial when the district
attorney stood up almost immediately and
said judge we're not going to retry him
that meant the charges at that moment
were dropped when vincent walked out of
here last night he said he wanted a
crawfish dinner so he got it
what's next for him
he says he wants to leave louisiana and
start again somewhere else
wow wow well david we can certainly
understand that uh congratulations to
you and your team for a lot of hard work
here there were a lot of people involved
working on this case for a lot of years
to to bring vincent simmons into the
outside world as a free man you
mentioned he's free but not exonerated
so i do have a question first of all who
met him there he was hugging two uh
ladies and there were some cheers i'm
curious who was there and also is there
any hope of restitution for the 44 years
he paid for a crime he says he didn't
commit
his sisters and his attorney met him
here and there is hope but it's going to
be hard the d.a said he would
essentially have to go to what is a
trial and convince a judge that he can
prove his innocence proving that he's
innocent may be difficult but when you
say that he had a lot of help tony it's
important to note every attorney who
helped him was simply using the
information that vincent had obtained
himself nobody believed vincent when he
stood up in front of a judge by himself
but he kept trying he kept trying and
was expecting to die here in prison
but instead
after 44 years he won
and the tragedy is david there are so
many more vincent simmons out there
david we thank you so much for this
incredible gift that you've given
to
the simmons family
and to cbs news